hello everybody welcome back to let's
play dead space okay come back out here
Oh is your office I don't know it the
asteroid still coming probably not ah no
not Mele you stupid man engineer
whatever whatever you're yeah get out of
here man I gotta go I don't have another
accident Kinnear oh you want some watch
that oh no and I'll wash your body parts
go flying off into the sky yes give me
that ammo no mama
inventories floggin uh I need to reload
I this is wasting time this is wasting
time bro not worth it find out worth it
oh that probably killed me uh okay I'm
okay
alright now turned on the automatic
asteroid killer machine and I don't know
why it was off in the first place can
the aliens figure out how to okay I
don't know or maybe it was just that big
giant goofy
everywhere that's caused the problem
probably oh there we go that's my med
kit I don't need to know wait whoa
Isaac Hammond you're not gonna believe
this all levels are falling something
more Bob you're monix air production and
whatever it is it's filling the deck up
with that organic stuff we're not going
to have any air to breathe soon but if I
understand these lab reports correctly I
think I can make a poison to destroy it
well that's convenient had to medical it
should have everything you need
well this never end no will it Isaac get
to medical and mixed together whatever
Kendra's come up with I'm heading to
hydroponics if I can slow it down that
might keep us breathing long enough to
fight it yeah that's why how you die
because you're actually going to try to
do something which I'm glad that you're
being proactive but that probably also
means you're gonna die
whatever man
I seem to be obsessed with that matches
up perfectly
who's out there I'm ready for you
Oh what the hell
it's a head it's a head you hear we you
is it dead
oh it's a head I was there just a head
oh why is it moving I'm not doing that
it's just moving yeah yeah there's a was
it whoa Moorhead's I saw that come here
ah I get here don't come here don't come
here ah sorry
ah you're a pan Wow why are their body
parts moving around on their own this
really is like the thing oh my god this
is so
so the thing is it if you don't know
what I'm talking about go look up the
thing it's this is exactly like this was
in the movie you know hands detached and
what did their own thing and they look
just like that is this the thing in the
future always just the origin of the
thing Oh fun
the thing well the thing was alien maybe
maybe maybe a super-smart
maybe I figured this cracked this case
wide open
longest elevator ever there we go okay
I'll bring it on I need a story
hey who was that asteroids you should be
gone already
I turn on the super gun all right
whatever
I don't even know if I'm on the right
but I need to know or I know I need to
move for Scott to arrange kinetic
booster device that doesn't sound is
impressive well I as I thought of all
right give me the med packs old
semiconductor tone ten thousand that's
like Oh whole that's one power note Wow
all right thank you
come on imbibe our note
one more yeah hell yeah I've got so much
money in so many paranoids I don't even
know what did you would hi no oh that
supposed to be scary oh oh what's that
one behind me
haha predicted it Oh called it out of
the blue I know your tricks you can't
get me I'm so cray hey Dad
oh yeah Oh Europe you you used to be a
lady sorry what happened to you does it
gross alright even I have standards
madam one in the tram yeah I knew better
there are ads up here that's it that's a
nice touch I guess that's sort of
emphasizing that this place used to be
like a living breathing ship so of
course it would be advertisement
everywhere alright let's see I'll save
ya sure why not
yep by him okay another chapter down man
we're making progress
lethal devotion again with the ominous
titles of chapters
I'll bring it on of so many Oh was that
wait oh I'm back on the medical wait
geez Isaac I can smell the contaminated
air from here it's spreading faster than
I expected I'm trying to isolate it but
it's not gonna buy us much time we have
to get that thing off the ship
what's the chemicals you need are in the
chemistry lab I'll hack the door for you
when you get there uh-huh
fine sure you will will you betray me
and stop you in the back oh no do not
manikin me I swear to Aisha
Zeus looks like a mannequin Oh grab the
door locked on this deck and recently -
I guess we're not alone here after all
someone doesn't want you in this part of
ship not mannequin me I guess I
shouldn't complain it's a very effective
scare tactic but I do not like it
you I don't trust you hi who's there oh
hey get out it nope nope nope ten
bullets in your ha no no no no no I lose
12 bullets I don't like this it's much
darker is that just me is that where
that guy hammered his face into the wall
his body is now gone
I don't like this yeah this fears much
creepier where do these what are these
candle things would come from whoa whoa
whoa what the heck oh that door is open
aya Marcus from Amma nice little bonus I
guess I'm gonna be returning I was
wondering why so many of the the lockers
were red I guess I'm gonna be returning
to places around the ship eventually be
able to change suddenly all right oh you
know what I'm upgrading oh yeah I want
that I want the damage I get there I'm
trying not to waste these notes so if I
can get I won that one
four five and six but I want to keep one
so
yeah let's go this way there we go okay
even more damaging to my assault rifle
oh man
totally finish the game oh I don't trust
you
who's out there
oh whoa oh
they kill you
what were you I don't even know oh you
didn't have the common courtesy to drop
me some ammo so everybody
yeah slap you across the face all right
that was locked um am I going okay back
up the same way I came why do I need to
go back the same way
oh what's that scream daddy a very
creepy scream true true - okay whoa whoa
hey baby I did not even see you you guys
see that I totally missed him okay I'm
guessing just on a wild guess he just
aces it don't trust you don't trust
anyone
great great you know advice in life
don't remember the chemistry station
once you did the chemicals you're also
going to need a DNA sample of the alien
tissue all sorts the records for one
don't trust that no no you the guy that
was bashing his head into the wall
you're missing as much flash as he was I
don't like this I don't like this
all right actually I have to cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in the next part bye bye